he is none other than Sean Payton how
are you coach I'm doing well rich thanks
for having me on what that time of year
it is that time what number training
camp is this for you total oh let's see
this is uh well with the Saints this is
thirteen right and then in the NFL
shooting when I add four six this is
gonna be 22 I'm sorry I was I did tell
you there would be no math in this
interview my apologies and add nine more
from college I don't think training camp
but we called it two days in college so
I'm just going NFL here 22 so what what
do you hope to achieve I mean what is
like obviously coach's plan and and your
you're just like any other head coach
where you're trying to control
everything that you possibly can I mean
what what possible what what how do you
approach a training camp coach well I
think this and and I was taught this in
putting together a roster the most
important decisions are the right 53 and
you know there are certain positions you
kind of can pencil guys in at and yet
finding finding the right 53 in the
right practice squad and and then also
understanding if if they're not in the
building don't make the mistake in
creating the right 53 or the right 10
practice squad players so I think that's
the number one thing us and the 31 other
NFL teams you know are are charged with
here in the in the upcoming month is is
is the proper evaluation you know you
don't want a good player to get out of
the building that maybe didn't get a
good evaluation because he was nicked up
or injured or for whatever reason so I
think that's the that's the most
important thing when you say not in the
building you're talking about again
evaluating what other other teams are
doing and who they might cut and
bringing that player in despite not
having been in your camp all yes I'm
relying oftentimes a mistake sometimes
is made specifically by the coaches
where
well we we can't replace this player
because there's no one behind them if
this player doesn't fit or is not good
enough then the best way to create that
cavity is is to not invest and continue
training the player I you know in other
words it's the old adage of changing out
a dishwasher
you know if you have them haul it away
you're gonna find another dishwasher and
so I just say that in a term and not in
a callous term there
you know year one in 2006 which ended up
being a pretty good season for us
two of our three starting linebackers
came the week prior to the start of the
regular season with that in mark
Simoneau and Scott Shanley now we're
further along in our program in 2019 but
so it when we talk about the evaluation
you know it's it's on this roster and
then a is it good enough period at that
position you know it's sometimes if you
just say well that's who we have and
it's you fall into that rut where you
never make the correction or the change
Sean Payton here on the Rich Eisen show
it's obvious that you have the
quarterback all all situated and the
conversation with Brees he hears it all
the time he even heard it on the ESPYs
red carpet a couple weeks ago is how
much longer do you ever have that
conversation with him honestly and I've
been asked that a few times not not once
I mean not even like a tingly dance
around it at all we just I feel like
number one you don't see age when you're
around somebody so much it's not until
their children come running in the
stairwell or in the meeting rooms or
that you that you're like wow you know
there everyone's growing up but it isn't
something that that we discuss there are
a lot of other things that we cover but
there's never that sit-down hey let's
let's spend some time here and talk
about the next couple of years because I
think look he's he's so competitive and
I think like any one of us in our work
industry or our job you know until we
don't feel like we can perform to the
level we've been used to then I think
that he looks at it I'm sure on a
year-to-year basis and just like quite
frankly I do well I mean you're I'm
already hearing in certain parts of my
industry that last year certainly in the
last few weeks of the season breeze
wasn't as productive at the position and
maybe that's the beginning of the the
lowering of the curve what did you see
from your position I didn't see that I
didn't see that at all I mean I thought
- I mean he played extremely well down
the stretch we had a cloud win against
Philadelphia that he had a huge part in
in a game against the Rams that you know
quite honestly very well kind of put us
in the Super Bowl and I would have loved
to have seen that game but I think that
realistically as we grade the film and
look at the player that there hasn't
been there hasn't been that moment where
we've looked and talked man back in the
day we used to complete those you know
that and I don't think we've seen that
and that's a good thing sure Sean Payton
here from the New Orleans Saints here on
the Rich Eisen show okay I'm gonna bring
this up with you well and I'm sure as
you pointed out last time every human
being brings it up with you the pass
interference that didn't get called in
the NFC Championship game and you as a
member of the competition committee
certainly helped spearhead the the
change that we're gonna see this fall at
least for one year al river on the head
of NFL refs came and presented to the
NFL Media Group how this is gonna work
and we were all stunned in the room Sean
to be very honest with you because we we
we couldn't agree half the time on
whether a play was OPI or dpi or would
we have thrown a flag on the play in
real time or would we have picked it up
through replay would we have instituted
field for all that stuff and all that
conversation including looking under the
hood and seeing because instant replay
could review whatever is reviewable OPI
offensive pass interference being called
via replay to make an offsetting penalty
and none of that stuff is what I believe
was the intent of what what you
spearheaded I wonder what you think
about the potential unintended
consequences of of this one-year project
well hopefully their their minimal we're
not splitting an atom here and I think
sometimes we collectively can can
certainly complicate things ourselves
we're from the from the very beginning
clear and obvious has been a standard
that the coaches have spoken about we we
understand that if it goes to and let's
back up I think for the fan just to make
sure that everyone understands it these
challenges are gonna fall just like our
no normal challenges do and so I don't
think you're gonna have or see a lot of
them we still start the game with two
challenge flags and you know it's 2019 I
kid all the time but it's literally a
challenge flag is a orange handkerchief
with two ounces of sand and two rubber
bands around it and when we disagree
with the call we launch that onto the
field so with only having two of them
coaches are going to make sure that they
certainly have one towards the end of
games you get a third if your first two
or right and so P I pass interference
and offensive pass interference are
added to this and I think when you add
significant penalties like that that
could be worth more you know call it the
bonus round or more points and whether a
player was in bounds or out of bounds
for a gain of eight yards I think you're
going to see not more challenge about
flags but I think you're gonna see less
actually inside of two minutes then the
upstairs group can can stop
play but I think from my perspective you
know I the third down plays I don't have
to worry about the scoring plays they
already go to review so it's it's the
big plays where I feel like something
occur certainly last year's play in our
game that would have phone to the replay
official and that was kind of clear and
obvious so I'd like to explain it that
way and start that way I don't think
we're going to have a ton of game
stoppages because again we haven't
changed the Challenge numbers
I do think another important element to
these games as we get into the
postseason is the elimination of the
all-star crews what I mean by that is
the you know all the all the officials
that have graded out the highest
singularly as opposed to as a crew end
up working games with other officials
that are graded out the highest but they
haven't ordered games together before or
they haven't worked games certainly as
many as they have with the crew that
they were with all season I think that
had as much to do it.why
when you when you look at a player a
foul that's missed you know at that very
moment there's two guys that are working
the game that have never really worked
together before and I think that's human
nature one's going to acquiesce to the
other if he feels like he has it where
if they'd work week week by week
together and it'd been part of the same
crew I think it's a lot easier to say no
I got a better look at that so but I
don't I don't think I'm hopeful and and
I don't think it's going to be that
traumatic of a change I think we're
gonna have to see clear clear evidence
and the play you're referring to there
was OPI you know again when we go to the
challenge system and we go under the
hood and we look at it in New York and
at that moment any of the any of the
fouls that or any of the plays that are
subject to review
you know you're looking at a catch no
catch but while you're looking you
notice that a foots out of bounds or
something else has occurred and that
subject to be part of the review but I
don't think it's going to add I don't
think it's going to open up a Pandora's
box of other issues well I hope not yet
because you know again let's take a Sean
Payton here in the Rich Eisen show what
your answer let's take them one at a
time the play that that al Riverrun
showed and he's gonna be here on Friday
on my show and I'm gonna forward that
what I'm about to forward to you to him
as well the play you're talking about
was at the end of Thursday Night
Football in Kansas City a remarkable
play but finished between the Chargers
and the Chiefs that might not have
happened if under the current construct
a big pass interference call would be
waived off because offensive pass
interference was caught in the replay
process and in last year it seemed that
the the helmet-to-helmet stuff that was
a huge moment of one year ago almost at
the all Hall of Fame game last year that
throughout the preseason there was a
conversation about how it would be it
would be handled in the regular season
and it really wasn't much of an issue
because the preseason handled a lot of
the ironing out of wrinkles is it
possible maybe to in between now and the
beginning of the season to just say that
yeah when you open review replay
everything that you're viewable can be
reviewed but just not pass interference
that if you open replay to look at was a
dpi you cannot then say oh it was
offensive pass interference as well I
mean can you can you make that
distinction well listen certainly last
year when it came to helmet to helmet
there was a point in that in the early
part of the season where you know powers
to be reconvened and said hey let's make
sure we're communicating yes to the
masses the groups I think along the same
topic man we have to continue to push
for and set forth the goal where all of
these officials that were working with
hand in hand just just as we're coaching
and playing our
time I think currently a third a little
less than a third or full-time meaning
that two thirds of these officials on
Monday are you know at a school or at a
you know an office an attorney's office
accountant counselor they have other
jobs and and I think that we're at that
point relative to the preparation the
amount of time and the speed of the game
has gotten to where it's harder and
harder for these guys to be part-time
yeah there can be exceptions though
without without a doubt rich I think
that I think the committee sits in there
and enroute you know you really go
through all of these examples that we're
discussing and you get on conference
calls with coaches from other teams and
you begin to hash out and work through
some of the problems so when year one
will this be smooth sailing I'm hopeful
that that it doesn't change how we watch
a game I'm hopeful that it is something
that you know what we're relying on is
for the clear and obvious and we're not
you know looking to to change every play
and yet only time will tell and then and
their last part of your answer our
all-star crews again
the fans are thinking about the
beginning of the season training camp
fantasy teams but for the mind's eye are
for the playoffs our all-star crews
going to be banned or you're not that's
it I think this is going back to really
great in the overall crew performance
that was something we finished
discussing at the owners meetings and
agreed upon because at that moment if
you and I have never met and we're
playing golf the first six seven holes
we're going to you know there's there's
a certain chemistry that exists maybe or
that doesn't exist that if we were the
regular Friday tee time and I think in
that case you can you can actually see
that take place with two officials that
hadn't worked together one felt he had a
pretty good angle on an actual
he didn't and the other had an
outstanding angle it was the same angle
we had his coaches and players on the
sidelines and he acquiesced to the
veteran official that that he just began
working with that day so that'll be a
change this year in postseason you're
gonna see the crews basically for the
most part be the crews that work
together all year the few minutes I have
left with you Sean Payton you're
bringing up golf you're bringing up
officials I have to mention at Lake
Tahoe we saw you take a shot from the
front of a boat was that official
sanctioned drop area was that dove from
the back of a boat it was I was two I
was two feet in the water
mm-hmm and you know obviously that's not
a good spot to be but deep enough to
where I didn't feel like I could hit it
out of the water and yeah I could take a
drop on on the wet sand next to a beer
can and the official says that's one
option and then the second option I
asked him I said well like can I take
this drop right here yeah on this back
of the boat and he said if you can get
the ball to stick so the first time I
dropped it it rolled off in the water
the second time I dropped it it kind of
found its place in that scene it's a
terrible lot of know if that's a
terrible it was it was but you know I
was fortunate just the challenge on that
shot was not the lie either though the
picture this you're hitting the shot
with that lie and and your whole your
whole boat is moving I felt like I was
doing a core workout trying to trying to
hit this wedge yeah and it looked like
the water right yeah well your body your
reaction and it looks like uh you might
have scold it but it looks like you you
Vin Scully that thing it just did just
listen I didn't do a lot of things right
it that that day but that shot actually
came up on the green and ended up on the
back portion of the green I was I was
pretty pleased with it all right no I
just want to finish up our conversation
with something I brought up with you
last season midseason and you know if I
have a top three pick in my fantasy
draft coach
picking one two or three how safe am i
choosing alvin kamara with you how safe
um yeah I like to I like I like the
Camaro selection I think I listen that's
me I'm biased but I know that yeah
there's so many things he does well I
don't understand the type of fantasy
game you might be in you know he's got a
school it's got it like inside the font
you know I told you about the vulturing
the last time he's gonna be a guy that
scores so if it's a ppl or whatever
those I don't I don't know how those
know we have programs devoted to these
things but I would I would I like the
Camaro selection I know you got latavius
Murray now I mean that this can you know
obviously you feel free to conduct your
program how you see fit but I mean he's
a battering ram that concerns me inside
the five that if I take Camaro how do
you decide these things that's all I'm
saying
how do you decide these things I think a
lot of times it's week to week but I
lose the goal-line runner when you're
inside the three generally have a guy
and and look that's what we're getting
ready to go to camp for but I like
Camaro overall just from a yeah
explosive threat I mean he does so many
things as well
you're the best coach thanks to call a
great senior this past weekend I rear in
losses thank you you take care have a
great have a great camp that's Sean
Payton Saints head coach for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app